which no way home surprise appearance
means the most for the future of the mcu
it's hard to say when there are so many
to choose from let's take a look at that
cast list
you ready
i'm ready
fans surely recognize jay jonah jameson
when he briefly popped up and far from
home in the mid-credits scene that's
because actor j.k simmons reprised his
role as a daily bugle's shadiest
journalist and he's back on his beats in
no way home you certainly remember that
community editor in the original
spider-man trilogy who fleeces pizza
creates a smear campaign about our
friendly neighborhood spider-man and
frequently tries to get away with not
adequately paying his freelancers all in
all he's kind of a jerk in the comics
jameson first appeared on the pages of
the amazing spider-man issue 1 in 1963
but beyond his rich history with the
comics and the spidey universe as a
whole he's more relevant than ever
before in today's fake news and
alternative facts filled political
climate
it's the moment we've all been waiting
for daredevil has finally joined the mcu
okay matt murdock's spider-man no way
home cameo may be small and seemingly
insignificant but it actually changes
everything
that's it let the devil out
ever since marvel sold the film slash tv
rides to his vast catalogue to multiple
companies their respective worlds have
become a fractured kaleidoscope of
characters just out of reach from one
another for a long time the mcu didn't
have the rights to have spider-man join
the avengers and deadpool was in prison
with the x-men unable to hang out with
spidey despite their comic book
connections yet inch by inch we're
getting more leeway on which characters
can interact with each other
while charlie cox's cameo in no way home
merely consists of him taking on peter's
case once his identity has ousted the
scene is arguably one of the most
important moments in the movie why
because it opens up the door for all of
netflix's marvel shows to appear in the
mcu but possibilities are endless
okay tony stark we get it you're a cool
nerd and you kind of bully your droids
tony dooms his arm robot to a life of
mockery giving him a name like doom or
dummy but the bot makes the best of it
despite his savage name and occasional
dunce hat accessories in no way home
dummy watches honest peter works on some
tech for the alternate universe villains
giving the robot purpose even after his
creator's death tony didn't always treat
dummy very nicely but he is a creation
that tony made in his father's workshop
adding a sentimental component to the
butt dummy even saved stark's life once
when he couldn't reach his arc reactor
and didn't have the energy to keep
trying and it's a lovely nod to tony
that happy still keeps dummy in his
apartment of course with the state of
happy's apartment following green
goblin's bomb onslaught dummy might be a
gunner but it's nice to see tony's
friends honor him even after he's gone
we first meet the mcu's betty brandt
back in spider-man homecoming even then
she's a spunky reporter who banters on
air during the school's morning
announcements
in a couple of blink and you'll miss it
scenes and no way home betty pops up
reporting the goingsanita high school
it's nice to see her living out her
journalistic aspirations but seeing her
do social media videos for the daily
bugle makes us a bit uneasy betty brandt
is also a character in the original
spider-man trilogy you might remember
the sweet brunette woman who processes
peter's paychecks from the 2002 trilogy
well that's the ultimate universe is
betty hopefully the mcu version of
brandt takes a few healthy steps
backwards away from old jjj
you're an fos now friend of spider-man
and you have to remember just stay calm
ned leeds may seem like a normal nerd
with a superhero for a best friend but
no way home has fans wondering if
there's more than meets the eye to the
computer wiz ned accidentally conjures a
portal when he gets a hold of doctor
strange's slingering and single-handedly
brings the other peter parkers into the
movie how do you pull that off sure
magical rings are powerful and all but
they don't typically do that for just
anyone if it weren't for ned's apparent
magical abilities we would never see
andrew garfield and toby maguire's
respective spider-man show up on the
scene ned is so naturally talented with
sorcery that he even impresses the
doctor with his portal making
if doctor strange didn't wipe everyone's
memories of peter would have a good
chance of seeing ned take up the magic
arts even so his magical abilities are
still a part of him and they will no
doubt show up down the line one way or
another in fact ned could be gearing up
to be the next strange or wonk dr
octopus aka dark arc aka dr otto
octavius doesn't get nearly enough
screen time in the og trilogy in the
comics he's often depicted as a member
of the sinister six a group of super
villains who have some major beef with
our friendly neighborhood spider-man yet
out of all the on-screen spider-man
villains we've seen in the movies
throughout the years dark arc is one of
the most sympathetic and likable
villains his octopus creations was never
for the power he wants to change the
world for the better but as we often see
play out in comic films it doesn't
exactly work out in his favor however
the duck gets his chance to shine in no
way home expanding on his original
redemption arc and digging deep into his
character for a more well-rounded arc
that allows him to become the hero and
save his fellow villains alternatively
we get a whole lot more backstory for
sandman and spider-man 3 than no way
home his cameo consists of helping out
peter a bit then lashing out at him and
finally just begging to get home to
whatever time period the villains end up
in he does end up cured so that's a
bonus point but his appearance is fairly
superficial outside of that detail
there's a pretty strong case for norman
osborn being the most fascinating and
exciting spider-man villain we've ever
seen grace our screens yet while his
chaotic energy is a blast to watch we
never really get much emotion or death
from willem dafoe's green goblin now
that's not to say that defoe's acting
isn't phenomenal but he's never given
the space to explore the deep psyche of
his character in the original trilogy
we've got a guy with an evil alter ego
who takes over his consciousness but he
rarely fights back that's a fascinating
study on the human condition but rather
than honing in on that power struggle we
get more demonic laughter and bomb
slinging than actual depth luckily no
way home gives to foe the opportunity to
brilliantly dig into the struggle
between good and evil and we see a
deeper more emotional side to norman
than we've ever witnessed on screen
green goblin certainly wasn't peter's
first villain in the comics flying onto
the pages in 1964 drawing the 14th issue
of the amazing spider-man however he's
easily a movie favorite for fans and he
finally gets his time to truly shine in
no way home
dr curtis connors or the lizard is
another one of spidey's oldest foes
first lettering on the scene in the
amazing spider-man issue 6. og trilogy
fans might remember a different version
of dr connors who serves as peter's
professor in the second and third films
while he aids pizza in his symbiote
research we never get a sense that he's
trying to turn himself into a lizard
hybrid in andrew garfield's the amazing
spider-man though we get a full-fledged
lizard in all of his scaly glory the
film does a great job setting his
descent into the sewers in motion as he
gets deeper and deeper into his felony
yet with the redemption arc already in
the books at the end of garfield's first
movie no way home doesn't spend as much
time fleshing out his character the
lizard is a fascinating tale of a dream
gone awry despite its best intentions
the minute things started going south
the good doctor should have bailed on
his mission hopefully the peters
convinced him not to go down that road
again
as great as sam raimi's original trilogy
was at creating epic villains for toby
maguire's films none of them get much in
the way of character exploration or a
backstory in the amazing spider-man 2
electro arguably has the most
well-developed and executed villainous
backstory of any spidey foe we've seen
on the big screen the movie spends ample
time building up his pre-villainous path
defining his humanity and ultimately
reaching his breaking point when the
world has just shafted him too much
electro is a cautionary tale on a dismal
world that's largely responsible for
creating a good number of its own
monsters while electro needs to be held
accountable for his actions had the
people of oz corp treated max better
maybe gwen would still be alive in
garfield's universe however as elektro
says the moral of the story is you've
got to be careful where you fall when
you live in a sci-fi world electro made
his first appearance in the amazing
spider-man issue 9 in 1964. elektro
doesn't get a whole lot of screen time
and no way home and most fans could do
without simba's merching tony's arc
reactor but his appearance does tease
one thing miles morales he muses how he
wishes there was a black spider-man and
that he hopes there's a universe where
that's true which any spidey fan can
confirm could this be the film's subtle
way of introducing miles into the mcu
aunt may we know her we love her and now
we mourn her over the years we've
watched countless iterations of
spider-man lose uncle ben and begin his
on-screen journey in the same place with
the same repeated plotline when some
holland spider-man debuted he offered a
refreshing change of pace from the story
we've seen repeated time and time again
instead of uncle ben being in the
picture we have a younger version of
aunt may that spices up the story
however this is still a spider-man tale
so it was only a matter of time before
may uttered ben's iconic words with
great power there must also come great
responsibility but we also know what
those words are prelude for death we may
watch aunt may die in no way home but
her compassion and belief in the best of
people saves a handful of villains and
sets peter on his journey to become the
best web slinger he can possibly be
for some reason andrew garfield
spider-man tends to get the shaft when
it comes to fan favorite spideys but he
provided a refreshing take on the hero
back in 2012 yet his storyline felt
incomplete with just two films under his
belt we leave off the amazing spider-man
2 following the tragic death of peter's
true love gwen stacy and he attempts to
give up his role as spider-man after
watching gwen fall down a tower to her
death for just a second too late to
catch her peter is a shell of his former
self you're wrong about us being on
different paths we're not on different
paths through my path
and you're always going to be my path
when we meet peter again in their way
home it's clear that gwen's death still
haunts him what ifs and guilt plague him
but his shot at redemption in holland's
third film marks one of the movie's best
moments when holland's mj falls in an
eerily similar way as gwen garfield's
peter does what he failed to do before
save the girl the moment is everything
fans wished it could have been back in
garfield's second film by saving our
peter's girl he heals some of the wounds
he's been ignoring for years
it's poetic lovely and honors the
wonderful spider-man that garfield
brought to life with his cameo in no way
home fans can rest easy knowing their
spidey gets some closure and prevents
another pizza from a lifetime of grief
he never stops grappling with
fans tend to stand toby maguire's
spider-man but our original webslinger
isn't without his faults from the very
first moments maguire's peter gets his
power he uses it to get back at his
bully and fight people he didn't have
the strength to stand up to before and
sure they usually deserve it but once
you give in to that initial impulse it's
even harder to stop yourself the next
time especially when you have super
powers
whether it's finding uncle ben's alleged
killer fighting green goblin or getting
back at mj peter is quick to fall into
anger and vengeance mode and it's cost
him some of the people he loves most
however no way home offers the original
peter a chance to right his wrongs by
lending a helping hand to the nearest
spider-man when holland's peter parker
is hurting from losing his aunt may
toby's pizza helps him work through it
sparing norman but most importantly
sparing his webbed counterpart from
besmirching makes memory with murder
while maguire's third spider-man film
leaves a lot to be desired his
appearance in no way home offers a much
more cathartic ending for the older
wiser spidey
before the amazing spider-man comic
series came into play flash thompson
made his marvel debut in amazing fantasy
issue 15. for anyone who needs brushing
up on their spider-man comics history
that's the very same issue that spidey
himself debuted as it stands flash and
peter have been intertwined in a web
since the very beginning so it's not
surprising he has a deeper history than
we have yet to see on screen in
spider-man 3 the introduction of the
symbiote and venom provides the perfect
opportunity to give flash played by joe
main ganello the chance to shine instead
that honor goes to its more common host
eddie brock played by topher grace
however it looks like the mcu might be
heading in a different direction
following no way home's first
post-credits scene which sees some
symbiote goo left behind in the mcu but
no eddie bruck flash has a laundry list
of experiences involving the symbiotes
in the comics including becoming regular
old venom anti-venom and agent venom
will mcu flash be the next venom we'll
have to wait and see
it's feeling a little strange around
here no there's no denying that strange
is a bit of his game in no way home with
his jumbled spell work and quite a few
hiccups in his all-knowing plans given
how often doctor strange has screwed
with time travel memory spells and other
finicky magic it was only a matter of
time before his meddling caught up with
him and it appears that time has come
the post post-credits scenes as more
like a trailer for doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and it boasts a
pretty big baddie evil doctor strange
now this isn't the first time the mcu
has dabbled with the dust to lead dr
strange the what-if episode what if
doctor strange lost his heart instead of
his hands offers fans a glimpse of what
could happen if strange fell down a
rabbit hole of obsession in his attempts
to rewrite history each time the
sorcerer plays god he gets closer and
closer to becoming a shell of his former
self we spend all of no way home
examining how good people can become
villains and while we don't know
precisely what sparks has changed and
strange it's not looking good for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
buckle up kids it looks like we may see
the necromancer version of strange
reminiscent of his 70s counter-earth
comics run
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more luba videos about no
way home are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one